Because here's the truth. This ruined three lives [music] minimum.
Actually, that's not true. She had kids. It ruined all of her
kids' lives. It ruined her life. It ruined her wife's life. It's
going to ruin this police officer's life. Yeah. Monkey see monkey
do. Okay? Do not do something the other monkey won't do. If the
monkey tells you go do something, and the monkey isn't doing
it, tell that monkey the [__] off. Okay? Why are
you telling me to do it? Why aren't you doing this? Why aren't
you putting your body on the line? Why aren't you doing this?
Okay.
[music]
Okay. Asold's got these videos, so
I'm I'm probably just going to go We'll jump into his coverage
really quickly. We'll watch a little bit of this right off the
>> Dude, he he he's like, "I won. I won." The second that
video gets dropped, he just thinks he won entirely. Right. And
I will say this changes a little bit for me in terms of
like did they have a reason to go grab her? It does seem like
probably she had been already like blocking traffic. She probably
was there for that purpose explicitly, right?
But again, I still don't think she deserves to be killed on that.
I do think it makes it a question of did they were they exercising
their authority appropriately. I still don't think she should
have been shot. I think there's every reason to deescalate and
but they probably had some reason to go over and try to detain
her. >> How we doing, boys? >> How we doing?
>> He's so badly won.
>> Man, I uh
>> not new video of the ice shooting. I
>> No one. Yeah, I didn't say that. More flows. I think
transitively because she was obstructing she was
but you don't have to literally it's about if they had no reason
to go over if they had no authority to go over and try to pull
her out of her vehicle they created the situation they might
actually be in trouble right
okay
Zortician
are you a [__]
if cops have the right to stop you and you're in a vehicle if
they have the right to detain you you're in a vehicle they probably
almost certainly have the right to pull you out of that vehicle?
No.
In what universe do they have the right to detain you, but not
the right to pull you out of your vehicle?
They aren't cops, though.
Okay. Maybe uh maybe people just weren't here and I have to speak
from the very
So, ICE seems to have some authority to detain people
if they are obstructing an active ICE operation. These people
are obstructing an active ICE operation. They are intentionally
doing it.
Can I send it on Discord? Yeah, go to the Discord and send in
the content links channel, Matt. Okay. They're they're
Uh they do have the right to detain people who are obstructing
investigation. I do think that would extend to pulling someone
out of their vehicle if they were trying to drive
She literally let another call pass by. Oh, hold on. Zortician,
I need you to really focus up. Okay, I'm going to play this clip
for you again, the original
Where is she here? And what is she
What was she doing right before this?
As in 30 seconds before she was shot in the
she's literally blocking traffic. And then what does she do when
the cops start walking around?
She pulls backwards.
She pulls backwards and gets out of the [__] way.
Okay.
Now, this person was already obstructing traffic. They were obstructing
some ICE operation. I do believe you have the right to detain
this person at this
Notice the smug smile, too. That is not going to affect whether
or not I think she deserved to die. This person's a mother. I
don't care how smug they are. I don't give a how smug they are.
Okay,
they this this mom, her kid doesn't deserve to be an orphan because
she was smug one time to a cop. That's insane.
I didn't know she had her dog with her. Yeah, I assume the cop
fired three shots cuz he hit her perfectly in the face the first
shot and then he fired two more trying to hit the dog. I think
that's probably what happened here. Okay, that's another reason
he's going to get off. He did fire the first shot in self-defense
and then just because he is a cop, he was trying to execute the
K9 in the back seat. That's the extra two shots. Okay. Pop pop
pop.
We're we're uncertain of if the dog got away or not yet. Okay.
So, she was obstructing. So, you could say she started waving
people through after and maybe she did, but she was obstructing
right before this.
Again, doesn't affect the analysis of whether she was really
a threat, whether she deserved to die, whether she was trying
to run somebody down, whether or not she's a domestic terrorist.
Okay. Just basically only factors in in terms of were they were
they at least somewhat tenuously authorized to go and walk over
to her vehicle and try to detain her. Yeah, probably.
Okay.
Anyway, I know I just got done watching it and uh it is insane
and uh I just uh honestly,
you know,
sometimes I get
I get tired of being right.
I do. It's like at a certain point, right? I mean, like you need
to have a degree of uh, you know, like a plot, [snorts] you know,
uh, diversity, right? I mean, but damn, it just seems like the
same thing happens every time. >> it does every single
time. What?
>> By the way, this goes again. All you need to do, okay,
dude,
there's like a critical contingent, okay, of like white supremacist
types who could really this whole thing up for
the right wing, okay? You need to reach out to those people.
Are you guys okay with them just beating the out of like white
people like this? Are you okay with them just like white parents,
people who have bunch of white kids? You're you're fine with
them executing white I swear this this like works long term.
Okay. I thought ICE was only going to be like illegals. What
the
what the why are they white people now? >> What about what
about that? And so uh I mean but damn, it just seems like the
same thing happens every time. >> I'm watching this video.
>> It does. So every single time. What do What about What
about that? And so uh they dropped the body cam footage. The
thing is that they actually didn't that he had a camera. See,
like I actually originally I thought it was body cams, too. But
he actually had a camera. And so, uh, yeah, I just got here.
They Every single one of these people needs to have a body cam.
Destiny's already saying the new video makes Ice look more guilty.
I like the thump thump. Oh,
Oh, why? Why? Why was he in the road? You know, like
what do you mean, guys? Like, no. No, you don't understand. No,
no, it makes perfect sense, guys. No, see, okay, if you All right,
if you close one eye and then barely open the other eye and then
turn your monitor upside down, you can kind of see how it might
not be her fault, right? And so, yeah, 100% justified. I said
it was I said it was
right at the beginning. It is the
cope. I I am I am so vindicated. I wasn't going to go live today.
I swear to God I wasn't going to go live today.
>> Okay. That might be the biggest lie I've heard on an
Asold stream in forever. Bro, when do you take days off? I wasn't
going to go live today. Yeah, good one. Like, come on, man. >> And
I saw this footage and I said, "Am I really going to miss a day
where I get to tell everybody that I was right?
You're not going to like this, but I am right.
I'm right. I know you're not going to like it, but I am right.
>> Here I am. And so anyway, ah, Jesus Christ. Maybe I
should have skipped the day. Give me a second.
>> Ah, okay.
>> I'll join [clears throat] up at >> How about that?
So, yeah. Uh, that's why I have that soda, right? This is a W
for you once again. I know. I know. Was George Floyd scandal
not similar to this? Uh, to an extent. I think that George Floyd
was a lot grayer than this if you want me to be honest. Right.
I mean, George Floyd never posed a threat to anybody other than
himself when he was doing fentanyl, right? Uh, I don't think
he really posed a threat to anybody, but um, you know, again,
I uh, and I want to let everybody know, uh, you know, they they
putting him on hog.
Uh, he's saying gray and then what he's actually saying is obviously
not a good situation. Obviously wasn't good for the cops, right?
He wasn't a threat to anybody. Then saying gray, that's that's
one of those things you say cuz you know your audience leans
a certain way. So you like don't want to say no, you're >> Watch
now. They got him on a hogwatch.
>> And so uh anyway, dry air. Yeah, he died from fentanyl.
I don't want to get into it, but my point is that uh you know
I did say this is what happened and I had everybody on the internet.
I never have had more people uh you know tell me that my parents
are dead. More people threaten me. More people uh you know say
crazy [__] and just like insane say insane bad stuff
to me then with this event. Right. I I
>> wait as a little aside
um Asminold did step in to get very upset about the the doxing
of Oh, this was deleted by Crassenstein.
Why isn't this gay banned? Was what Asmin Gold asked when the
Crassen scene, one of the Brian Crassen scene, I think, has just
been posting the name of the the officer over and over and over
and over and over and over and over and over and over and over
and over and over again. Okay.
And Asminold comes along and goes, "Why isn't this guy banned?"
It's like, "Asminold, I want you to pretend that this officer
shot Charlie Kirk." Okay? For two seconds, just pretend that
this officer shot Charlie Kirk. Wait, no, no, no. Sorry. Pretend
that he laughed at Charlie Kirk. Pretend that he laughed at Charlie
Kirk. Okay,
now it's all fine. Right now he laughed at Charlie Kirk getting
shot. Isn't that Now he deserves it. Right? He didn't deserve
it for capping this random mom, okay, for orphaning multiple
children. He didn't deserve it for that. But now that you've
know, now that you know, okay, somebody needs to get this guy's
face and use AI, use some AI program to make a TikTok of him
laughing at Charlie Kirk's death, and then Asmin Gold will be
entirely on board. Okay, 100%.
Uh, actually, they should put this guy in jail forever. He laughed
at Charlie. Yeah, now I do think he's a murderer, actually. Yeah,
I just thought this was funny because uh Dead Domain responded
to him. Okay. said some bad words. Catch a look in the mirror,
did you? You f slur swamp skeleton looking
as gold. Of course, nothing sticks to as gold. Okay, thank you
for using that word. I've been working hard to bring it back
and I appreciate your contribution to the cause.
[laughter]
I'm sorry. He says, you can't you can't beat this guy on a lot
of grounds, okay? Talking about how he looks,
calling him names, I it literally just slides off. It's that's
never going to happen, right? Trying to show where he's wrong.
I think that affects him more, but yeah, you just call him like
names. He doesn't give a [__]
there's another interesting thing going along with this, just
the whole like doxing thing with um
with the cop and
I saw like another discussion around this. I think [singing]
now I didn't see the whole thing, so I actually need to check,
but Wick and Adam friended had a back and forth. I do kind of
want to see what was going on
Let's see here.
Go like this.
Wick asks.
>> Wick asks,
"Why isn't this guy banned? What do you think he should be banned
for? Inciting violence." Uh, doxing, how is it doxing when the
news is was reporting his name? I mean,
again, it's doxing. It's about what the public interest is and
why they're reporting his name, right?
I think in this case you could maybe argue public interest on
like along the lines of you probably want to report on his other
cases and stuff.
do you think it's good to know the identity of an officer of
the state who's just shot someone? I think you could. So it's
always going to be a balance, right, of whether or not this is
in the public interest versus what like the propensity to cause
harm. And I think when you are somebody who thinks this guy is
like guilty of murder and you're just trying to say his name
over and over again, right? Because if you didn't see Brian Crassenstein,
this is deleted, but there are some Brian Crassen Brian Crassenstein
tweets of him just saying the name over and over and over again.
Like hold on, Brian
Crassenstein. And then what was the guy's name? I forget his
name now. It's all out there, right?
It wasn't
What the was this guy's name? Why did I just I lost it entirely.
>> What was this dude's name? Somebody just type in chat.
Jonathan Ross. Thank you.
Brian Crassenstein.
Is this the deleted one?
>> Yeah, he he started he went with this one after the
fact, but in a couple different cases he was like
>> he was literally I think it was just like a page all
bold like maximum size. Jonathan Ross, Jonathan Ross, Jonathan
Ross, Jonathan Ross, Jonathan Ross, Jonathan Ross all like page
like a page of that. Okay,
>> I'm sure somebody's got it saved
Doxing should never be encouraged in this situation or any other
for that
Dude, where is it? Somebody can find it, I'm sure. I'm guessing
he's deleted it by now. But
should try to find it at some point. Okay, back to this. Uh,
inciting violence, says Adam. Then him and Wick, I think, getting
a back and forth here.
Citing violence
here. Let me get back to this one. Okay. What do you think he
should be banned for? Doxing is a necessary component to stochastic
terrorism. Think about it, Wick. If you lived in a world where
you couldn't track someone online by their name, do you really
think doxers would be so eager to publish that information?
Right? It's like basically Adam comes along and does say this
is this is very true, right?
Hold on. This is this is absolutely true is that I think Brian
Crassenstein was actually
like obviously
trying to do something
No. Am I crazy? I'm pretty sure when he like spams the name over
and over again.
I He is like trying to He's trying to make a point. Okay, he
is. And I do think Brian Crenstein was 100% doing that. And
I don't really think it's it's doubtful. I just I want to see
I just think it's funny that Adam came along and said this, right?
And I just want to see how Wick responds to that in general that
it just it's going to be funny to me how Wick responds to this.
I'm pretty sure.
Did the news dox him here? Is me posting this news report of
him doxing him? No,
it's not the riskreward question. The real question is, do you
think the utility of the public knowing his name outweighs the
security threat harassment his family will get? If you want his
family to be harassed, then it then that is the utility. Yes.
I think that armed agents of the state who have been authorized
to use lethal force, being able to be accountable to the public
outweighs the risk of that they are
Yeah, I think
dude I
Yeah, it's like okay, how is the that the question is how is
the public going to hold him accountable, right?
like what what is the method by which the public will hold this
person
>> that that won't be possible if it's just the government
that knows his name
like in this case I think there's probably some argument you
could get to which is well the government isn't going to hold
him accountable I should be able to know this guy's name so that
you know if I ever see him I if I ever deal with him I can like
like basically say I deny him whatever I can tell this guy off
or
>> but I don't know. I'm not surprised law enforcement
is pulling back from actually helping people. Why risk your life
for people like you? Huh?
Okay.
Military, police, politicians, etc. all have powers and protections
not afforded to civilians. In exchange, we expect a level of
accountability and transparency that we do not expect of civilians.
Personally, I think officers and officials of the state should
be required to identify themselves except under very specific
circumstances. undercover agents, special forces, or some
uh that's not that's not wrong. I think that's probably true.
I think again, this seems to be more of a policy disagreement
that these people get to be like masked and hide their identities.
That's probably wrong, right? But I also think what Crassenstein
was doing was wrong.
So, this is this is probably true. This is way more reasonable
than I
What is the utility in broadcasting his name everywhere? Mostly
two in this. Oh, hold on. uh to know if they are actually an
agent of the state or not just someone posing as an agent to
know if this person has a history of bad behavior. So I know
if ICE is keeping agents keeping on agents who have a history
of bad behavior. Um I would just say you probably leave this
to Legacy Media as best you can at this point. Again, I
I know for a fact that this guy now just gets and this is the
problem here, right? This guy 100% now gets millions of dollars.
Literally all this guy has to do is make like four fake Twitter
accounts, four like get one burner phone number, call in a death
threat to himself, make four death threats over Twitter to himself
and he gets to be a millionaire.
I He understands that, right? Like automatically he just understands
that now he gets to be a millionaire.
He was always getting the money. Who cares?
I don't think you should be allowed to crowdfund off of stuff
like this if you're if you're an officer.
I don't think you should be able to crowdund. They should be
prevented or like you're fired from your job. One of the two.
I don't think you should be able to have like an officer related
shooting that goes viral, right?
Nothing about doxing changes the situation. He name was always
going to come out. Nothing about his name coming out changes
the situation. his name was always going to come out. Okay, that's
seems like very circular stupid logic,
I understand that his name probably comes out eventually. I mean,
it was published by news agencies. I don't think this is necessarily
like I don't think what Wick's doing is a problem, right? What
Brian Crassenstein's doing is a problem.
That's going beyond just the the names, right?
So, it's one of those things where everybody's reacting to
like the crassenstein thing instead of Wick.
But I I do agree with like I think this guy's name was going
to come out. I do think it's in the public interest
specifically in terms of news agencies running down like what
this guy was arrested sorry what this guy had a court case about
before trying to see if this guy has a history of like getting
violent with people. I would say I would want to see the body
cam footage of where he breaks through that dude's window. I
want to see that. I want to know like is this guy just poorly
reading situations and escalating
That's what I would be concerned about, right? You know, is two
cases where he's tried to like with a vehicle and it's turned
into a life or death situation both times.
Like I would say as like as an officer like with what his job
is, having multiple life or death death situations a year is
probably too much. Like you're you're probably escalating things
in a way where like you're doing too much. You know what I'm
saying?
The ICE agent lives in his neighborhood. He had to go home and
deal with protesters. Yikes.
Yeah. He would be from Minnesota. So
is pretty crazy, man. All right.
I was dealing with messages like crazy. People were responding
like crazy. They were go they were going ape. But it sure seems
like in fact they were just going hog wild. [snorts] And it's
sad to see because I was right all along. Just like I knew I
was just like anybody who wasn't knew I was. And this is why
everybody watches me. This is why everybody looks at me. People
pay attention to me. They're listening to me. It's because I
just happen to be right on so many of these issues. And it's
really shocking, isn't it? And uh yeah, people are they sure
are. They definitely are. How do you respond? What's this here?
Uh the allegations you being bald today? I'm not. That's what
I'll respond. And so, [laughter]
okay, there are some things you could say about him apparently
that get to him. I guess that one's kind of predictable with
the hair such that it >> Oh yeah, there it is. Uh they
know you can be emotionally weak, but they forget you don't act
on your emotions. Things bother me, but I don't act on them.
You're right. And so anyway, uh I'm I'm massively
uh I I am totally vindicated by this. Uh again, the the obvious
thing that
So I think asminold, this might actually be true, but not for
like a good reason. I do think Asmin Gold's vindicated because
I do think that Asminold believes as well as I believe it's the
position of ICE and a lot of federal agencies
that like hey we have to start a couple people so these people
know that they shouldn't stand in our way like some people will
have to die so they learn to actually like follow procedure follow
protocol like it is genuinely like I I don't know how else to
describe it other than like kind of fascist right they do want
you to be scared to interact with them they do want you to be
scared such that you comply automatically they want somebody
to die for that reason. And I think Asminold's pretty openly
saying I do like he'll he'll phrase it differently like right
like
>> Asmin will say no no I would prefer they just go peacefully.
I would prefer they don't do anything like this, right? But then
the converse of that is still like we need some people as examples
who are going to do this. And I think he's said as much multiple
times like some people will have to be examples but then they'll
learn not to get in the way like this, right?
As far as I know, he's pretty open about that. Yeah. Exactly.
And he's like that's So I think basically he's been hoping this
would happen that somebody would get killed and now they got
killed and this is their example. And so I think he's basically
like, oh well, we're right on schedule. This is why, right? You're
not having an argument about like how much should people comply,
how much should they be able to, you know,
protest, what's what's legal there. It's like, no, no, no, no.
We need some people to die to the cops so that people are more
scared to protest the cops or block the cops from doing something,
right?
Like, unironically,
Asmin Gold could have maybe broken the civil rights movement.
Okay, we just need to sh some of these people like that. Like
that's honestly where he's at, right? We just need to shoot some
of these people, guys. We just need to Right. It's like, oh well,
I guess if you crack down in that way, if you're just going to
make it so people die.
Yeah. Oh, this was his first response. Yes. Everyone in this
post is calling for my arrest and banning for posting Jonathan
Ross. They are claiming I doxed him. Jonathan David Ross. Jonathan
David Ross. Jonathan David Ross. Jonathan. Reminder, everyone
is innocent until proven guilty. Never take the law into your
own hands. Stay peaceful.
Okay. Like this one. This one I'm like, okay. Yeah. Okay. Stay
peaceful. Yeah. It's the Trump special.
Stay peaceful.
Fight for your life, but stay peaceful. Stay very peaceful.
Person knew happened, actually happened, and that's the real
reality. So, yeah. Uh, there it is. Body cam footage. Uh, I don't
have to call it doxing. 42xx. I'm actually fine not calling it
doxing. It It does kind of muddy what doxing is a little bit,
right?
It does kind of muddy what doxing is. I would say this guy is
trying to maliciously like incite something is what I would say
is doing, right? And saying he's he's maliciously attempting
to incite something against this guy. So, it's different. Now,
when you maliciously try to incite some kind of like real world
world harm by posting somebody's private information,
it's like really it's just whether or not it's private that such
that it would fit within the the lines of doxing, right?
there's also the public interest. >> Listen to the wife
right before she drives off. We're going to look at the entire
thing. Okay. Where is like this like ratio look on YouTube video?
I have no idea. I don't even watch my own YouTube videos. I I
might look like maybe once uh I don't know once a week and see
like a car in the back. I did watch it, but like I didn't watch
it and like pay attention to every single little thing, right?
So, we're going to go through all of it. And so, yeah. Uh
uh similarly, libs of Tik Tok was journalism when they reached
national
Why?
I I disagree like what was the outcome? What was the positive
outcome in terms of the public what public interest was served
42x
doxing libs of Tik Tok?
I totally I completely disagree with this. That's like an insane
take.
There's literally no positive utility. Your your utility is Well,
I was
You get to find out more about the person. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
You you literally said it after I said it. Yeah. I just I was
curious about what they were like. I was curious about who they
were. That's not the public interest. You don't just get to know
anything you want about other people. That's not a public interest.
That's not a public good. That
there's obviously no reason to dox that person. The reason to
dox that person is you're trying to say, "We're going to do something
to you in real life. We're going to we're going to make sure
you're harassed. We're going to make sure you're [__]
with."
Oh, yeah. Maybe that's true. Possibly. I limbs of Tik Tok's probably
a pretty harmful person. So maybe it's fine in that way. But
there's no there's no like public utility argument there. That's
just you're doxing them back cuz they're doxing like other people,
right?
>> I saw a picture of another woman at a rally. She looks
crazy. We have a big problem. We do. And I tried to tell you
guys, I tried to say it, but nobody wanted to listen. What else
is new? So yeah, and uh the wife needs to be charged, maybe.
I don't know what happened. I have no idea. You can hear her
saying it's all my fault. Emotional intelligence is uh is top
of the scale. Yeah. Well, I wouldn't really call it intelligence.
I would call it stupidity. Uh there's a lot of people that use
their emotions to make decisions for them. And every single time,
like this is one thing for me.
Um I actually don't know if that was even known by the time Brian
Crassenstein was tweeting that Riyle. Maybe it was, maybe it
wasn't. I don't think that factored in one iota into whether
or not Brian Crassenstein was staying the name. That's like a
I that's fully just post hawk cope, right? >> Like I think
about in my life, have I ever made a decision when I was emotional
that ended up being the right
>> Nope. Never. Never happened. And you know what? It probably
I wonder if we could apply that lens to the cop. I wonder if
we could apply that lens to the cop who was getting called fat
by these random lesbians. No, probably not. Probably just lesbians.
>> And so that's the reason why. And so I tried to totally
avoid that. And another chud wesh.
I know it's embarrassing, isn't it? It really is. Words for the
wise. I think it was referring to your high. Yeah. No, I have
a very high emotional intelligence. The thing is that my emotional
intelligence is actually so high that people think that it's
low. It's kind of like, you know, people think that Einstein
was because he couldn't read. Well, like that's the same thing
with me. I can't get a girlfriend, but I can figure these situations
out. So, yeah, it's pretty much the same thing.
[laughter] What can I say?
Wait,
listen, we'll talk about his emotional intelligence in a second.
Spicy chatters get docked. Seems weird to think a cop someone
wouldn't be. Yeah, the whether or not he is like whether or not
he would get doxed is not is a totally separate conversation
from whether or not it's right to like try to get this guy try
to try to incite harassment against him. Entirely different >> The
new video with person proves the >> I could I could say
it was like by the way I'm not even ruling it out that it could
be in the public interest. I just don't think Brian Crassenstein
was doing that. Like there are reasons within the public interest
that you would post the information about that uh that officer.
I would just probably like to have it left to people who are
in the field to make those calls. Like journalists who are in
the field to make those calls. That's all. >> You shouldn't,
right? Yeah, I know. I know. I know. And so
>> another month, three months. Yeah, exactly. Stupid ones.
Yeah, we'll see how many Look at that. The look on her face as
she was accelerating. I know. I know, man. And the thing is also,
here's what's so annoying is that we literally That can't be
true, right?
That can't be true that this guy's dating Emiru. That's no. There's
no way, bro, if this guy was dating Emiru. Oh my
Oh my goodness. That would be crazy. Could you imagine? I don't
think it's possible. I don't think it's possible. Just going
to throw it out. Just going to throw it out there. I don't believe
that's true. I don't believe that's >> Have a, you know,
a a revolution going on in >> Okay, let's be real. The
the Emmy skitsos would know. Okay. They learned about mischief
fast enough. They would they would know
the rabbits would never starve again. Roaches for days.
I'm I'm sorry.
If this guy were dating Emmy, it would it literally
this the Emmy Skittles would know. Okay. They would just know
on and because these brain dead
are thinking that I'll always trust your gut, brother. That's
right, brother. This is an awesome update. Expiring violations.
I hate to say it because Destiny is so obnoxious and he always
misrepresents me.
I hate Destiny so much, but unban him from Twitch cuz he would
be fun to be on >> and he's annoying and he's said so many
stupid things, but Destiny should get unbanned from Twitch. He
should He's He was banned unfairly. It was totally ridiculous
and he should have not ever been banned. So yeah, you see a clip
>> is banned unfairly. He violates the the toos in like
every way constantly. I think they're totally fine in keeping
him off. >> Hondur politicians getting domed with explosives.
No, I didn't see that. I didn't see it at all. Uh I I'll look
at it in a bit, but yeah. And [snorts] so um anyway, uh yeah,
let him back on. I think they should I think they should let
him back on. He's a not proven in court. I don't want to have
somebody get banned over an allegation like that, especially
whenever it seems like it's really gray. It's not like he's going
out and saying anything else.
Uh, also probably not a literal.
>> Okay, that's there's not a lot of evidence for that.
So, yeah. And uh,
>> not that I've ever said it in the first place. I always
correct people, but
>> they say he matured and did better this time and burned
and ludess in 2020.
>> Matt, thank you for the five gifted. You >> notice
how right the crowd is? Well, the reason why is that um you know
really I mean 2020 was a uh you know a perfect storm, right?
You had like 10 different things that happened. So yeah, it's
destiny to get on Destiny to stream on Rumble. I actually saw
Rumble is uh they added a new wallet. They're bringing new people
in.
>> I might actually start streaming on
>> I haven't completely decided yet. I'm not sure, but
um I'm considering it.
>> I think if I'm doing politics content, I got to stream
on Rumble. I'm pretty sure. some of the stuff about it. They
had like a new uh like a crypto wallet where you can like give
people money in >> Reban Ruben donated.
>> Asmin needs to take those rose tinted glasses off.
it took me half a second. I was only looking. I wasn't reading.
I was just listening and then I see the quotes and I Yeah. Okay.
Reuben Rubin. All right, buddy.
Uh if you're streaming to Twitch, why not Rumble, too? Well,
I will stream to Rumble, but the thing about Rumble is gonna
be if I were to catch on at Rumble and it's like a bunch of right-wingers,
man. I might uh
I might get audience captured, okay? These people start donating
a lot of money when I have like right-wing opinions. I might
be over for me, okay? I might be if I go to Rumble,
you understand? I won't be able to resist if they're just like,
"Here's here's like thousands of dollars if you go and have our
opinions." Why would that matter?
why why would that matter? It would matter. Yeah. If
it would matter if you are making a whole bunch of money.
I'm just I'm I'm trying to be realistic in that I obviously don't
plan to do that, but it does happen to everybody. Literally,
every single person who says, "Oh, I can't be bought. I can't
be like I can't have my opinions changed my money." Like, no,
you 100% can. >> [__] And so, uh, yeah, I might
do it. We'll see what happens. I gave her the benefit of the
doubt before uh before that. She was scared, man. It turns out
she was really hostile towards the
>> Oh, weak willed. Clad dumper. Go ahead and send me like
50 subs and show me that you can't be controlled by money.
>> How many do you even have any gifted subs in the chat?
I don't think you have any gifted subs. You could say weakwilled.
You don't have any money.
>> If you had money, then you could make this comment.
I guarantee if somebody was feeding you lots of money and you
you don't have money,
you you would understand completely.
You would get it. >> You thought she was scared. Why would
you think that a person that regularly seeks conflict over and
over with a federal officer and follows them across state lines
to seek even more conflict was scared? Why would you think that?
Like really, like this is the thing. All you have to >> Oh.
Oh no. Was that about her?
state law or just think you all this is I'm telling you guys
they figured this out like 3,000 years ago in Greece with logic
okay we have logic it was a gift from God you you don't you can
figure out the truth of almost anything just by thinking about
it you just think about it wait a minute oh gez guys OH NO
man what is this crazy UK might ban X I don't know about Why
is someone in Colorado agitating fellow federal officers in Minnesota?
Because she got skitsoed out by propaganda on the >> Greeks
invented logic. I think the Greeks did invent like formal logic.
No, wasn't a Greek philosopher invented formal logic. I don't
even think that's >> Internet, she's a victim. The reality
is she's a victim. She's a victim of herself and she's also a
victim of, you know, this uh sensationalized
uh hysterical
media frenzy about everything. That's the reality is you have
all these people that are hopped up. Look at this. Like, who
does who does this? What is this? This is crazy. You've got these
hogs getting rounded up. Like, I would think this is an AI video.
And so,
>> yeah, here we go again. I know. Here we go again. Here
we go again. And so, anyway, uh very appropriate. And and here's
the funny thing about it, okay, guys?
They're not going to admit that they were wrong. They won't.
They will not admit it because they've already
that they're right. >> And so they're not going to say,
"Oh, well, with this new evidence that's presented, this shows
things in a different light." Seems like actually the woman was
maintaining eye contact with the officer as she drove her car
directly at him, and he just barely got out of the way. Uh yeah.
I I wonder if they're going to say that and you're so cooked
as a country. It's unbelievable. I know. I know. The United States
is such a it it's such a stupid country. >> But I get it.
Said that she should have minded her own business.
>> We get to him
in the world that and we got two problems in this world. There
it is.
Have you seen the uh the left's cope of she was turning? She
was turning. She was. It's No, she was she was undeniably turning.
She was and
in the process of that, she hit the officer.
>> Can't do that.
Can't run somebody over in the process of turning your car.
>> I just think if he was being honest, he could probably
describe it accurately, right? Like the guy wasn't getting run
over. You can't you can't bump somebody with your car.
You can't if if you're being honest, just say you can't bump
an officer. You can't nudge an officer with your car and live,
right? You can't nudge an officer with your car and live is what
his opinion is.
But because these people can't be honest, that's how you know
they're like basically lying.
Asmin Gold comes the closest to being like less about this. At
least Asmin goal is kind of openly saying, "No, I do want to
kill people just to set a precedent. I do want to kill people
just to like make a point." So that's that's cool in that he's
a little less about it, but you should just say the specific
thing like I think if you nudge a cop with your car um trying
to get out of the way, trying to flee from them, you should die.
That's what Asold thinks. You see the dinosaur in the new video
that's made a bunch of people think it's AI, but it's not. There's
an actual dinosaur statue thing in that neighborhood. Nope. If
I'm doing donuts in a parking lot, I'm turning. But if I hit
somebody while I'm doing donuts in a parking lot, uh I I committed
a crime. That's the way it works. And so yeah, and still can't
do that. So Yep. And uh I I can't say I hate him the way I do
because you'll ban me in my in your chat. I ha No, no, no, no,
no. Okay, I have to ban you. Okay, I don't want to ban you because
I probably agree with you, >> but [clears throat] I I have
to ban you. Keep that in mind. All right, >> so keep it
in mind. She was doing donuts as a crime, too. It is. And if
it wasn't for ICE agent, uh, the left wouldn't even be mad. Oh,
if he ran over, he committed murder, you're saying. So, you're
clearly wrong. Nope, not at all. She looked right at him. She
accelerated in his direction. He had every reason to believe
that she was trying to run him over. And then he shot her. And
then he shot her again. And two more. There's a there's a fantastic
Deeperama doing some
Deeperama seems like a meme Twitter account. Okay. But then he
has he has some some posts sometimes
that are like they're very informative and they're very
how would you describe it? Tur,
right? They're they're like compact. They get the point across
immediately. Okay. I like I like this one recently.
I'm going actually repost this. The first thing they teach you
in leftwing in the leftwing terrorism handbook is to slightly
reverse for a second before attempting to hit someone who is
already in front of your car. Pathy. Yeah, they're pathy, right?
Exactly. It's like she's trying to get out of the way. It's like
Yeah. They teach you the first thing they teach you
to order in an orderly fashion try to back up and reorient your
vehicle to
It's like clearly if she was just trying to run the guy over,
she would have just hit drive and flown off, right? In fact,
she'd probably be alive. I'm not joking. She would almost certainly
be alive. If she just run this guy down in cold blood, if she
just been like boom, pedal to the metal before he could react,
that guy would be dead. Well, sorry, that guy would be run over.
I don't know if he'd be dead. That guy' be run over. She'd be
alive.
She would have gone back. They would have had to arrest her.
It's like if anything, no I won't say that. If
never give them an idea that you're going to run before you run.
Okay? You just if you're ever going to run, you have to think
it and then you you need to act. You can never signal that you're
going to run. Okay? You just have to act >> times because
this is a person like imagine are are you going to
>> she got out of the car when directed. She would be alive.
Where too are you talking to somebody else? Are you talking to
me? Cuz literally nobody disagrees with that. Right or left?
Everybody agrees with that statement. You just said something
that is worthless to everybody. You just made a completely worthless
statement. Not often that happens. Okay. Although in this chat
it seemingly happens more often than regularly. Okay. But you
just made a completely worthless statement that helps nobody
and solves nothing.
1 plus 1 is two. Hey, here I am with you. 1 plus 1 is two. Let's
go. >> Say that whenever somebody's shooting at you with
a gun and they're reloading that, oh wait a minute, I can't shoot
them right now. Maybe they might not want to shoot me. No. The
moment that somebody tries to aggress on you with a car, a car
can kill you. You can I hear these these streaks that they get
in Europe. Sorry for
uh this is obviously stupid by the way. Um actually when people
like speed up into a crowd, when people already have speed and
they they accelerate and go full speed into a crowd, you can
kill a lot of people. Cool. Was that happening here? Is that
literally does that have anything to do with h with what's happening
here? Did she do that? Did she do anything like
Just as useless as days of coverage. Smiley face. Wrong. Days
of coverage provides me lots of money that I can use to feed
my family, feed myself. Okay, that's what days of coverage gives
me. I don't know what you got for your comment. I when I cover
this stuff that really doesn't materially change the world, I
get a lot of money. So, I again,
I'm winning. You're losing. I I don't know why you did it, but
I hope you feel better. Uh, just as useless as days of coverage.
You're also useless. I I'm Yeah, I'm useless, but aren't you
kind of useless, too? I I hope that gives you some sort of sucker.
Okay. I hope you feel better. There's some some some
bomb there for the >> I mean, this is probably a you know,
uh, what's the word that people always use for me? Uh, brusk.
Um, you know, flagrant.
uh mean just this is not really politically correct language,
right? But like look at the political look at the look at the
streaks they get in Europe whenever they drive a car through
a Christmas market. There's like 15 20 people dead. Somebody
does a shooting, there's only like five or 10 at the most usually.
That's the facts. And so cars are more dangerous than guns are
by a mile. Unless you've got a 50 caliber machine gun uh and
you know or your Anders Breick, it's not going to happen. you
don't have a lot of people doing that. And so anyway, there's
a there's a video for this image is from above the reply. Scroll
up. And uh Oh, wait. There's another one. Oh my god. >> This
is the video I was talking about. This is the >> Oh, actually,
I should be able to find this video. I think I like this video
specifically so I could find it later.
I I noticed that I've been not doing that enough like liking
videos cuz cuz then they change your algorithm,
right? Oh, no. Nope. Nope. So this is this is Karen obliteration
day. It is >> all of the lies and everything else that
they had said and it's Jesus reading every day as a Chinese.
>> Right. Right. Okay. He's Chinese now.
>> the manga accounts defending this body cam footage reveal
them to be either bloodthirsty monsters who love to murder lib
women or the biggest in history who are deathly afraid of a Honda
pilot going 3 miles an hour. Do not see an in between.
Um,
yeah. I think I think by the time the guy fires the weapon, he's
just upset. That's it.
Because bloodthirsty. And this is the thing. The MAGA accounts
that defend this body
cam footage are revealed to be bloodthirsty monsters who love
to murder live women or the biggest in history who are deathly
afraid of a Honda Pilot going 3 miles an hour.
I wonder if Tim Miller wants to sign up to get run over by a
Honda Pilot.
I'd sign up to be put in that exact position. You You could put
me in that guy's position. I'd sign up for that any day of the
week. Yeah, I'd sign up for that. You could throw me in that
position. Like literally wake me up in the middle of the night.
Blackbag me, take me to like some military site, put me in that
exact position. I don't feel like I'm going to have to execute
this woman. I think and Asmin Gold admits as much, right? I again
The guy's just angry that his authority was his authority was
flouted. Also, do you know what? Do you know what happens whenever
a car Did you know that a rocket ship goes 3 miles an hour? >> It
does. And do you know what happens after that? It begins it continues
I I know. I know. I know it sounds crazy, but that's the way
cars work. So, even a a bullet at some point inside of its trajectory
will be going 3 m an hour. This is it. It's just
It's so stupid.
It's almost It It It's almost like It's not real. It really is.
It's so unbelievably dishonest and stupid that I can't even imagine
why people would think like this.
It It's crazy.
Like a >> I think these
not not the same I don't have the same basis for my belief. I
don't I'm not pointing at the same people, but I skitso. They're
absolutely out of their mouth. Sorry. And uh yeah, and if that
10 mill guy, what an idiot. What's crazy to me is they take is
that they don't take the the weight of the car into account that
it's not about them taking the weight of the car into or not
into account. It's not about that at all. It's just very funny
that he's doing this whole thing when I do believe he's literally
on camera accepting that yeah, she wasn't like he wasn't in any
danger like she was turning away. She was driving away. Do you
think 100? No, he literally knows that she was driving away,
that this didn't like this didn't actually this wasn't a real
threat to him. And so, but he keeps saying like, "What if you're
going to be run over?" It's like, well, I I think he already
by the time he's executing her, he knows he's not getting run
over, moged. I don't know what.
Let's be real, okay?
He did it better.
This guy runs someone over. Doesn't even get charged. Okay. White
woman. Random white woman from Minnesota runs someone over.
Dead.
Clav. Clav one again. Retroactively. Cloud one. >> The
ISIS claiming the officer feared that Renee go was about to seriously
injure a moment. Uh not really at that moment. And this is this
is another one right is you have the continuous
like continuous ongoing non-stop
That's all they do is that they just sit out there and they lie.
They literally just go out there and they say things that didn't
happen. They're totally disingenuous.
They lie about everything. Like, and by the way, it's the same
as ICE had no authority to stop her. They absolutely did. They
100% did. They're federal officers. She's impeding a federal
operation. That's a federal crime. Federal officers can arrest
you for a federal crime. Wait, but did he say that before he
knew it or cuz I would say if somebody says you don't like yesterday
I didn't say she wasn't doing that right yesterday I was saying
well I need to see evidence of her doing that now I do believe
she was doing that right and I do believe there's some reasonable
there's some reasonable thing going on here where I would believe
that they had a reason to try to stop her okay still doesn't
excuse shooting her in the face
uh they literally cannot re I'm pretty sure they can twisted
rope I'm pretty sure they're allowed to arrest people who obstruct
their investigations
or or their operations.
>> I'm I'm pretty sure >> it's just the law. Look
it up. Look it up on Google. That's the way it is. So, yeah,
it's literally that simple.
And so, anyway, uh Liptards
Exactly.
>> Twisted Rogue, do you want to do you want to cite me
something that says that they have no authority even when they're
being impeded?
If you want to if you want to site me somebody who's h who has
the opinion that even if they're impeding an investigation that
they're not allowed sorry even if somebody's impeding their investigation
they're not allowed to arrest or detain that person that would
shock me but if you want to cite that I would that would be cool
we could cook with that. >> So she's driving in front of
them without looking in this moment then she's not looking the
guy she's running into exactly
>> they're allowed to detain people but my understanding
is that they're not allowed to arrest American civilians. Wait,
what do you then? What do you mean by they're allowed to detain
people? Are you saying that American civilians could just form
like a a circle around some immigrant and slowly like walk them
out like they're Spartans with the shield wall? Okay. And they
could just like build this shield wall up and walk this illegal
immigrant out because while they can actually detain illegals,
they can't detain anybody in that shield wall. So forming that
perfect shield, that is the perfect barrier for ICE. That seems
unreasonable to me. Okay,
that's what a lot of people actually think. Okay, well that's
I'm saying that probably sounds absurd to me that that can't
possibly be true,
but if it is true, I would love to see somebody like standing
on business on that opinion.
Okay, but Twisted Rope, you understand that they're trying to
detain this person, right? So that's if you're saying they can't
literally arrest them and hold them for 24 48 hours, then sure,
but they're trying to detain this person. So it's kind of like
a pointless, meaningless distinction you made in my opinion.
No, that like you're saying, well, they can't arrest her. They
can only detain her. It's like, well, that's what they're trying
to do. They're trying to detain her. And so yeah,
and uh the more people probably die as a result of cars yearly
than gun violence. Uh I looked that up. Um it is that is true
if you take out um
you can hear her hit him. Yeah, you can. You can. Why can't you
say both sides are wrong in this situation? You're leaning too
aggressively on one side and getting disgustingly mad about it.
I think that's actually one of the better chat messages I've
heard towards Aspen Gold on this. I do think like I do think
you no matter what if you want to be fair you have to admit both
sides up pretty badly and Asmin Gold if I know Asmin Gold he'll
go well I would do that and this guy did make mistakes but people
are lying about it so badly that I can't even I can't even talk
about those that's that's the way you go right see how closely
I have this guy soul right we'll see if this >> because
I don't think that they were I think the officer behaved completely
fairly I think HE DID NOT >> OH THAT'S ROUGH. That's rough.
I thought he would I thought he'd still try to stick to the both
sides in a little bit. I think he's gotten push back too much.
I think he's got to He's got to fully bear down. Yeah, I need
to update the model a little bit. I'm updating the model. He's
to fully bear down in this right now. He needs to fully He needs
to fully like go and and try to own the win on this.
>> Shouting does the car doesn't deescalate the situation.
Doesn't deescalate the situation. Even if I disagree with the
woman fleeing, she drove the car into
She drove a car into a person.
Um, if the photos come out and the cop has massive bruise or
injury in his legs, does that alter your opinion at all?
No.
No. Um, because again,
there was not a serious risk of like harm
by the time he like caps this woman, you know, by the time he's
firing the shots through the passenger window. doesn't meaningful
meaningfully change anything. Again, just so you know, I'm talking
about my moral read on this, my mind read on
Legally, I am positive he will get off. Legally, I am positive
they will not set a precedent that this like razor thin margin
for error is like what cops have to be held up to. Legally, no
shot. Legally, this guy getting off 100%. I'll bet anybody on
this one. Okay. Legally, this guy's 100% going to get off. Morally,
I truly believe he just executed this woman for upsetting him.
What are you thinking?
What are you thinking? That that that's this isn't two sides.
She drove a car into somebody. There you go. It's over. Just
watch it already. Okay. These people have Oh, I I you you might
not have seen the footage. Okay. You're going to see the footage.
Here we go. All right. Let's watch it. Here
we go.
You play it back from his angle. You can see him change the hand
that he's holding the phone from his non-dominant hand. Um, he
gets ready to then continues in front of the car. Oh. So, okay.
Maybe >> this is the I thought it was a body cam. It turned
out to be a cell phone. So, this right here is the footage that's
being spread everywhere on the internet.
And here we go.
So he gets out of the car. Dogs in the
>> I feel like it's
You can see she very clearly.
>> Are you sure? >> Looks at him. She acknowledges.
She's smiling at him. This isn't somebody who's scared. At least
they don't look
>> She's definitely not scared. I don't think she would
be scared yet. Right.
>> That's fine, dude. >> I'm not mad, boy. Show your
face.
>> That's in his left hand right there. Is it not?
That's literally in his left hand. We see the reflection. Or
am I getting [__] by the mirror?
>> Mhm. Wait. No. Hold on. I'm getting [__]
by the mirror, right? >> Because it's a mirror.
>> That it's his far away hand. So, it's his right hand.
on your hand. >> No, no, no, no, no. That's got to be that's
got to be his right hand, right? Cuz he's technically you think
about it's mirrored, right? It's in his right hand. Even though
it's his left hand as it appears in the mirror image, it's obviously
his right hand because that's how mirrors work. Got it. I nailed
it. >> And you can see very clearly he This is a phone
camera. And this guy probably learned his lesson from last time
somebody tried to run him over. So, he's got his camera out.
By the way,
there have to be body cams.
I think that like where where's JD Vance tweeted about this,
right?
>> Oh, he tweets back >> sends the >> the people
the whole argument against Kyle Written House about going across
state lines was like stupid
>> and I knew changes >> like two minutes. Hold on.
>> And so
what do you what do you mean? Right. She you even hear that right
there. Drive did drive baby drive. Did she say that? Let me hear
it again.
Get out of the
>> Why would you say this?
>> To be fair, the wife apparently was distraught after
and said, "I got her killed." So, she does kind of she does kind
of take accountability for it. Okay. The wife literally says
like the wife is like sobbing in another video. I'm pretty sure
we watch it on stream. Maybe somebody can find it and send it
to me. She's like sobbing after the fact like, "I got her. I
got her killed.
>> Holy [__] This changes everything. Look,
I I I
>> don't It was obvious right from the beginning. It was
so obvious right from the beginning. It was so clear and I knew
and and by the way, I'm always >> I am. I'm always right
on these. It's crazy, but it happens every time. So, yes. And
uh it's escalated. Yes. She was the one that escalated it and
then she stepped away. The wife got her. The wife didn't get
her. She got herself kicked because she was the one that was
driving. And the the police officer was yelling at her, "Stop.
>> Go get yourself some lunch, big boy. >> Listen
to this. Go ahead. >> Out of the car." >> Out of
the car. He's saying out of the car. He's walking up to her saying,
"Out of the car. >> Some lunch, big boy. Go ahead. >> Out
of the car. >> Get out of the [__] car."
>> Three times he told her to get out of the car.
Three times.
>> They act like >> Hold on. You know, it's like
it's my opinion, by the way, that that like the lack of gun control
also creates this environment.
Like no other country has police interactions quite like this
because in America you literally have to always be ready to get
into a gunfight. Like that didn't come up come about here. But
the culture of like always being ready to to jump to lethal
that like comes about from the gun culture there that comes about
from constantly being ready to enter some lethal situation and
like the the kinds of people who become cops based on that like
dynamic, right?
Like this never happens in any other country. It's ju sorry any
other country, any other western democracy.
It does happen in other countries, okay? But then she might not
have even had to drive. Oh, you're a woman behind the
You know, you're you're in Saudi Arabia. You get your you get
your head cut off just for being a woman behind the wheel. Okay.
Very >> Grand Theft Auto. This is the This is
I genuinely think that a lot of these people on social media
and the media in general and a lot of these political
are totally to blame for this
and the government is.
I actually like when I see this,
you never get me with this allegation cuz I say every single
time, no, you should just comp you should just comply with the
cops. You're like a white woman with no criminal record. Just
comply. Just comply. Just comply.
Just comply, dude. The people who become cops in America, given
the pay and the risk, these aren't people with like a lot to
lose. These aren't people who are there to like do good a lot
of the time. Okay? Don't roll the dice on that one. My guy, do
not roll the dice on that. My lady or whatever the [__]
Okay. I I'm trying to think. That sounded weird, but I'm like
I said my guy and I'm like, wait, no. Woman. woman.
>> Dude, it's like I just don't understand why you would
why you would do this. >> This woman gets shot. It's sad
that that somebody that was a mother got like yes, obviously
I think it was justified, but it's sad to see something like
that happen.
I don't really think about like that a whole lot. It's sad it
happened. There's a differentiation here that Asmold might accept
that I think makes a difference in how you're seen by other people
and how you talk about the issue. I wouldn't say her is justified.
I'd say you you could argue the cop's actions are justified,
which I wouldn't argue personally. I don't believe, but I wouldn't
argue her was justified.
It's like something it's slightly different, right? Like I don't
because one implies that she did something that she now deserves
to be killed for. The other implies that the cop is acting in
a way that like while not not good, bad, right? Probably shouldn't
have happened. You could justify his his mental state. >> It
is what it is. But here's what I do >> It makes a difference.
>> She's the cookie. I want the cookie factory. And the
cookie factory that prints these people is the mainstream media.
The government's [__] approach to going after them.
And then on top of that, the entire social media apparatus that
gasses them up and tells them that they can commit a crime if
they're sufficiently agrieved.
They're the ones that have created the ecosystem that prints
these
over and over and over.
So the Oh man, there's like some funny stuff here cuz I do think
I would like to see cops at least with with protests like this.
I would like to see punishments for people who just obstruct.
I know everybody in my chat's going to hate that take. I would
like to see punishments for people who obstruct. You're just
obstructing like regular [__] right? If you're just
here obstructing officers intentionally, that's totally fine.
Yeah. Uh, arrest these people, find them, put them in jail if
it's bad enough, right? I do think that there are people who
just think it's good to always resist like the the wheels of
government.
Not not okay, right? But it should be something where it's like
inevitable. You do something like this, you are going to get
fined. You are going to get in trouble. It will be a problem
for you, right?
This is I sort of I said this with um but it's like it's I want
something justified. I said this with some kind of
There's like some kind Oh, well definitely the trucker protest
was the first one. So I'll just use the trucker protest because
I think the other one was a was like a pro Hamas protest or pro
pro anti-Israel protest and I I got pretty harsh on those kids.
So I'm not going to talk about that one. But in Canada with the
trucker protest, it was like, take all these guys out.
Um, take them out of their vehicles by force and then if they
don't have any broken bones, break an arm on the way out. Okay?
Actually break an arm. You should, it should cost you something
to protest like this. It shouldn't get you killed, but just systematically
roll people through like a an orderly line and just break one
forearm on the way out. Okay? Painful.
Um, delivers a message. Make sure people understand that, hey,
I hope this message was worth it. If it was, that's fine, right?
But break an arm on the way out so that they have some cost.
There needs to be a cost to doing things like this. You can't
obstruct society and make it less efficient and it not cost you
something. If you want to protest, it should cost you something.
You should you should go in understanding that it cost you something.
Sounds like JTO would bring back water cannons. I just think
if you're going to try to grind society to a halt, it should
cost you something. And personally, I think the approach in Canada
where they took they they like shut down these guys banks bank
bank accounts, that's like way worse to me. Like I think you
break an arm before you take somebody's bank like ability to
transact away.
That's my personal opinion, right?
Uh you were cooking till you started to cut your Well, it could
be fines, too, but I think people don't really understand or
care about fines. And then if they're already like if they don't
have money, then you've set them up in a situation with nothing
to lose, right?
But there there have to be penalties for people who are just
trying to obstruct things. Now, unfortunately, we've hit the
other side of that where in America, so that's my country, okay?
Where we have like rights where we don't have like a an authoritarian
regime trying to crack down on us. In America, the calculus changes
slightly and I haven't really updated the position in a while.
So, in America, I'm not totally sure cuz there is definitely
like we just had another person where Oh, this is the clip I
liked, right? What I don't want to endorse is behavior like this.
Like to me, this person needs to be off the job. Okay,
this this person in this video needs to be fired, maybe find
a significant amount of money. Watch this. This is in Minnesota
again, right?
Someone hit this guy with a snowball.
And he walks over and puts a machine gun in their faces.
Fired, fined, possibly jailed. Get this guy the out of here.
Okay, cuz this is the exact kind of attitude that got somebody
shot in the first place. Like, this can't be allowed to happen.
It's not a machine gun. Isn't it a smoke gun? Oh, sorry. I thought
it was a machine gun. That's my bad. When I read this, I was
like, machine gun.
Apparently, that's some non-lethal gun.
You see the guy who pulled out his pistol? Apparently, I've seen
people pull out their pistols multiple times. I thought this
was another example.
But if that's a non-lethal gun, then that's fine.
If that's a non-lethal gun, then that's fine. CBP points gun
directly at protesters's head. Is this a different one? Sorry,
that's my bad. That's my bad. I didn't mean to do misinfo there.
I saw this wasn't noted, and then maybe it's now noted. Is it
noted on the Tennessee Holler page?
Points his gun and armed protesters. Uh, these these should be
getting noted because they're ah, okay, that's just the that's
just the bag. That's just the That's just the airbag. Okay. That
close and it's pretty bad in any case.
Oh, this is this is going to be the same thing.
Oh, no. It's not the same thing. This is somebody's sidearm now.
Is that Is that a gun or is that a taser?
It looks like a gun,
but it could be a taser. It could be another non-lethal.
This is the kind of [__] where I'm just like, "Dude,
you have to
you you have to fire the people who do this. It's possible I
cross these two stories over in my head." Okay,
it's a pain. It must be a non-lethal weapon in his other hand,
right? He like drops that and pulls his pistol out.
Why would they fire them? They like this. Yeah, I agree with
you. They like this and it's up. I totally agree with you. They
do like this. This is like the goal,
right? Is to get Again, just listen to Asmin Gold. He's actually
speaking for like what the the broader movement wants. They I
I want people's arms broken. I want people's like people like
fined. I want some, you know, stepping up some some hierarchy
to how people are punished so that this doesn't happen, right?
I don't want this not just so this doesn't happen as in this
should happen at some point. It shouldn't. Not in this case anyway.
I don't mind officers defending themselves. Like if you had a
if you had a full-on like legion of people running at you with
with actual, you know, weapons, you get into some like But that
I've never seen that happen, right? Uh there are situations where
I would defend an officer shooting people. I I think this is
insane.
But again, Asma Gold, people like him want someone, right? They
want they want the examples of people getting shot and so that
other people stop protesting.
They are spawning radicals. There's more of them every single
day. And it's bringing things to absolute chaos. It's total chaos.
Now,
I don't disagree with that entirely. I do think there is a there
is like a commensurate movement of lefty types of not just leftists
but like liberals as well who are trying to get people to resist
every step of the way, who are trying to get get people to go
out and obstruct in any way they can.
And while I think like peaceful demonstration is okay, I do think
if you're going to peacefully demonstrate like this, you should
be careful. You should be like make sure that they don't have
a reason to go, "Well, she accelerated. She like drove towards
this guy." You have to It's the same as the civil rights marches,
okay? Where it's like, "Yeah, they're gonna they're going to
attack us. They're going to [__] us up with dogs
and and you have to be perfect. It's not fair. It's not cool.
It's not good. It's totally unfair. It's totally it's not justice.
But you have to do it. We have to rise above this because we
we're making a point, right?
You need to as much as possible not have imperfect actors like
this, right?
And I do think there are people who gas these people up who would
never go out and protest, who are like, "Know your rights. You
should go out and protest. You should go out and obstruct." And
they're never going to leave their computers. And I do think
those people share a little bit of burden for this woman's death.
This woman thinking that she could do all of this and she wouldn't
be putting herself in danger cuz this is the opposite of the
situation I thought about, right? This is the very opposite.
I thought she was going to be terrified and driving away. She's
the opposite. She's totally calm. She's so calm she thinks she
could like slowly pull out of here with the cop in front of her
vehicle and they're not going to do some crazy [__]
It's just like, "No, no, I'm pretty sure they're going to do
some crazy [__] They've been doing crazy for a while.
Your rights and rights and laws do not apply. Your rights do
apply, but guess
How much how much is she served in Jade?
Let's say they put this cop away for
That bring this kid's mom back. That that bring this mom back.
Okay. Is her kid any less orphaned?
Like sometimes you got to think about that, right? I had a guy
I used to work with. I had a guy I used to work with uh my first
internship at a university and we go to like this cafe that was
on the university grounds for lunch sometimes and we'd have to
walk across this like um this crosswalk where everywhere on the
university grounds you have the right away as a pedestrian. Every
every car on this on on the university grounds has to stop for
pedestrians. Okay? At any crosswalk, any intersection, you have
to stop and let pedestrians go by. Pedestrians have the right
of way at all times.
And this guy
who I used to work with would intentionally not look both ways
before crossing the street.
I have the right of way. I have the right of way. I have the
right of way. Why would I look? Why would I stop? He would see
cars coming and he would walk
Okay, that's what this is like where it's like, okay, I get it.
You're in the right. You're absolutely in the right. How does
that help you?
I'd like to tell you that that guy I watched that guy get hit
by a car and break his hip and go through surgery and all of
this stuff. I didn't. He never got hit. Some cars barely stopped.
Some cars didn't notice him and went by and he jumped out of
the way. Okay. There's like three times where where I thought
things were getting like I I thought I was going to see this
guy get killed or something. Okay.
So, you could be totally in the right, but please, for the love
of God, try to protect yourself. Okay,
don't die and go, well, I yeah, I'm brain dead now, but I have
the right away. I was correct. Okay, but was it based? It was
technically based, not literally based. It was technically technically
that guy was holding to his beliefs to an insane extent, thus
that we would say he's based now.
I think he jumped into mud one time. Okay. Yes, he jumped into
like a puddle one time up his clothes. Okay.
But that was all he got for it. You have the media saying, "Oh,
well, it's it's ICE. It's not they're they're secret police.
They're they their their thing says police. She's following them
the entire day. If she didn't think that they were police, why
the is she following them? Then on top of that, they have lights
on their cars. Again,
all all I'm hearing is this guy this guy wanted to send a message.
Asminold wanted him to send a message. Asminold's going to defend
him. Even though he knows it's wrong, he's going to defend him
because he wanted this guy to send a >> They're fully decked
out in police gear. They're acting. >> That guy sounds
cool as he was. He was
such that he like I had to try to coach him through social interactions
with people so he wouldn't get fired. He was like a better programmer
than me by a lot. By a lot. Okay. But he just couldn't have conversations
with people. I think I was at that company longer >> being
like police officers. Every single thing points that they're
police officers, but you're trying to pretend like they're not.
It's just insane. She knew. She knew they were police officers.
That's it.
The wife could be charged with telling her to drive. I think
they should. I think they
Okay,
I'm I'm gonna go on a limb here and say that,
you know, participating in some way in getting her partner, you
know, her partner's kid orphaned. I'm going to say that's enough
of a punishment already. You probably don't have to go and try
to charge her for saying drive.
Like, come on, man. >> Absolutely should charge her. They
should. They think they can commit crimes so long as they see
themselves as the good guys. This vigilant,
dude, this this entire By the way, this entire stream we're reacting
to could just be reacted to with a literal mirror emoji. Okay.
The entire time you just do like the mirror emote. Just just
mirror every single time.
They're allowed to commit crimes as long as they're against the
bad guys. Yes. True. Yes. That is your entire country thinks
that on both sides. Anti-justice
fantasy that these people are selling on the internet needs to
die.
before more people die. This has to
You can't go out and obstruct federal investigations.
You can't drive over federal officers. You can't ignore lawful
orders. You can't decide in the minute of you being detained
whether you think I have to learn how to do this better, okay,
if I want to get bigger on stream. is I when he says you can't
drive over federal officers even though he's admitted multiple
times now that she wasn't going to run him over the wheels were
turned he wasn't getting driven over right I need to learn how
to ignore that in the back of my head trying to speak like the
truth I need to understand that the narrative supersedes the
truth in all cases I need to just like I need to teach myself
to just lie about that I could be so much better at this if I
would just be comfortable lying about that pick a side >> that
it's justified or not and if you disagree with it you just get
to drive away that's not the way the world works. And somewhere
down the line, we lied to these people and we told them that
it
And now somebody is dead.
Everybody who advocated drive away. Everybody who said ICE are
secret police, don't listen to them. Don't follow their orders.
Everybody who said that uh you know, oh you know, like make sure
to fight back against ICE. Put your body on the line. they are
the ones that are responsible for this.
Um, I would say like that, yeah, I would say some of that is
just totally unacceptable. You shouldn't be saying that you shouldn't
be encouraging people to go out and get themselves killed. I
do think he's hitting on something that is real that does exist
that there's this like entitlement where people think I can go
and do this and I won't ever be hurt for it. I won't ever be
punished for it. I
I listen.
Monkey see, monkey do is the law of the jungle for a reason.
Okay?
I would only take this advice from somebody who's going to do
it. Okay? If you're if you're online and somebody's giving you
advice and they don't do the thing they're telling you to do.
Yeah. Monkey see monkey do. Okay? Do not do something the other
monkey won't do. If the monkey tells you go do something and
the monkey isn't doing it, tell that monkey to [__]
off. Okay? Why are you telling me to do it? Why aren't you doing
this? Why aren't you putting your body on the lot? Why aren't
you doing this? Okay,
because here's the truth. This ruined three lives minimum. Actually,
that's not true. She had kids. It ruined all of her kids' lives.
It ruined her life. It ruined her wife's life. It's going to
ruin this police officer's life. You have probably a
That police officer is getting off of this. That That police
officer is going to be hailed by a hero by anybody he cares about.
That police officer is going to make millions of dollars saying
he got harassed. That police officer is on easy street. This
woman driving her car bumping this guy slightly is the best thing
that just that ever happened to this guy's life. It is the absolute
best thing that's ever happened to him. Okay? He's going to make
millions of dollars off of this. Do not get it twisted. If he
if he doesn't open a GoFundMe account, then he's a better person
than I think he is. >> Dozen people >> put a timer
on his lifespan. No, he's not going to get killed.
Why would you think he's going to get?
I don't think so. Very much doubt it. I do think he's going to
get harassed.
Okay. Won't be a GoFundMe. Will be a give and go. Maybe. Uh,
Maximus, thank you for the 20 months from the butterfly effect
of this who are going to have their life irreparably damaged
and altered and made tremendously worse. Not to mention her who
died.
All for what?
For what?
So you can get social media likes
and then she dies.
Those are powerful.
It's
It's absolutely disgusting.
>> These idiots got too hyped up on Marvel movies without
realizing they can't fight. Superman's bullet. >> Luigi
is the hero of the left.
But I don't think Luigi's just the hero of the left. I think
there's a lot of right-wingers who like Luigi, too. I'm sorry.
Luigi is the hero of like the populists. Okay. Now, there are
more openly left-leaning populists than there are right-leaning.
Well, no, that's not even true, bro. I I think a lot more people
like Luigi than than anyone will admit. I think a lot of right-wingers
are basically like, you know what, the hero of the horseshoe
is a good way to describe it. One took over. Yes. the hero of
anybody who's ever thought, which is, by the way, all of the
manga people. Anybody who's ever thought someone got to do something
about this. Seriously, anyone who's ever thought that, okay,
that's who idolizes Luigi. I think Luigi became less of a right-wing
hero when left-wing women started like thirsting over him, okay?
But when it when it was just a healthcare CEO that got popped,
those people were like, "This guy's awesome. Love this guy."
And then a bunch of like left-wing Tik Tok women started thirsting
over him. They're like, "Oh, that guy's actually gay." Shooting
that healthcare CEO is gay. I hate that.
>> What proof? You're [snorts] not. Her GoFundMe is a 1.5
mill. >> You think auto renew subs should count towards
the goal? Yeah, they should. Yeah, I think they should.
I don't want to listen.
Realistically, I want the timer on the stream to not really be
a thing we think about. I would rather that just like go up automatically.
We not think about it at all. I just do it because there was
a time period where I was getting like
there was a time period where I needed more time to do stuff
off stream and so I started doing the timer because I'm like
okay I'm I'm going to stay if you guys don't pay or sorry I'm
going to leave if you guys aren't like paying if it's not good
content. If we're not feeling it I'll take off, right?
So I don't like realistically I want to try to stream eight hours
most nights anyway. The timer is just sort of a thing that gives
me a reason to go and and chill. It's like a reminder to chill
basically. million. Good for her. I mean, again, like I don't
have a problem with people wanting to support the family. I feel
bad for the family. That's terrible that that happened to them.
It is. It's horrible. But >> does he not realize the wife's
probably a part of the family here? The wife's probably making
a lot of money. >> The reality is that this was justified.
It was.
>> So, it's almost by cop with so much mental people being
hoodwinkedked into this behavior. This is going to keep happening.
I definitely agree with you. Yes. And they keep making these
social media, you know, oh, give me a cookie for saying that
I'm a a revolutionary.
It's getting people.
It has to stop.
this entire rhetoric and all this violent language and everything.
By the way, every single
uh every single person involved in politics and policing knows
that if you go out and do this kind of like armed
operations out in the open in
you invite resistance,
right? That's why you only escalate like this when it's
There's no reason to believe that ICE's current like modest oper
leaning is okay, but if Charlie leaned just a little more to
the right, he'd still be with us.
>> Thank you so much, Reuben. Ruben, terrible, terrible
joke. Um,
you just made me lose my train of thought. I hate you now. Now
I hate you, Reuben. Ruben, now I hate you. Um,
[__] Where was I? I was like explicitly trying to
keep my train of thought and then I lost it.
Um, oh, about like inviting you invite resistance. So that's
why everybody was upset at Trump when he goes to put these like
armed armed police forces out. Like that is something everybody
knows, right? You go to put these armed police forces out. you
go in with ICE and you do these like extremely cruel overt operations
when you're not just like picking people up quietly which Obama
did by the way deported a people
you just pick people up quietly right doing these overt demonstrations
invites resistance and invites like escalation
that is obvious right
the only reason people care is because there are no no this is
stupid no this is there. By the way, people get very upset about
the National Guard going into places as well being like a militarized
presence. Yes, this is the thing is this this admin
wants escalation.
They want this to turn into escalation. That is the goal explicitly.
Come and come and fight with us. Come and get unruly. Come and
actually be like come and up because we want this. We want to
show that the left is violent. We want to show that these people
are going to break stuff, that they're going to protest and they're
going to burn down buildings. That's what they want, right? They
can run on that. That's awesome.
When you when you are not like this woman, but when you are like
somebody who's going to go and be violent like after this even,
you are explicitly fueling their political machine. So, you should
understand that.
Um, ISIS has been doing this since 2008. People are noticing
it now because they're not doing it quietly. Yeah, exactly. That's
what I just said. Yep.
That's that's the exact reason. Yeah. That's why Tim Wall said
don't riot. That's why they they're saying we're going to deploy
the National Guard to deal with any possible like unruliness.
They don't want riots. They don't want anything like that. That
is an explicit tool of the rightwing right now.
Oh, they uh the scamming mod was fired. Uh oh. thing against
the the officers, against the law enforcement, against police.
It has to stop.
And if it doesn't stop, more people will die.
Maybe it might be an officer next.
She got fired. Is she going to do another GoFundMe?
Dude, that I shouldn't laugh. I do genuinely think,
I'll be honest, I do genuinely think that that person was having
some like actual issues and I don't think it's necessarily funny
that they're gone.
Oh yeah, it's kind of rough. Um, this is their response. Uh,
I was like, "Oh go for my job. I'm checking myself into a mental
hospital for a bit. I will be offline for a little." Like I I
I do think that it was less of a scam and more her like quite
literally
like I I think she quite literally was having
like some some kind of episode and I do feel quite bad
and I understand that that can blend and and there could be like
rational self-interest there where she notices she's getting
like money from people and
it does it does I I feel bad and I don't want to judge this person
before I like
hear more. It sounds like she canceled her previous GoFundMe
as well.
I might have uh TA might have some sort of t Oh, TI might have
some sort of social media policies in place and she asked for
three GoFundMe in a year. No judgment or hate. I just hope she's
well, is able to bounce back from this.
>> yeah.
Uh, there there is some world where she was totally like um intentionally
scamming people as well.
>> Yeah, I actually agree with a lot of the posters here
that you probably just let this go.
>> Um, the person's like fired. It's kind of taken care
of.
scammed people out of 100k. Wait, she scammed people out of 100k.
So, she got the the funeral money, which was what? Five grand,
and then she got like 75 for the the niece thing, which could
be a scam. Yeah. Okay. I mean, it's close
Again, I don't know what's going on in her head, so I'm trying
to differentiate. Like, she may have something going on in her
head where she has like r like reasons. She's deluded herself
into thinking that this is all fine. I don't know.
Yeah, I just I personally like I feel bad for her in this way.
Um
because I I do think she probably believes that her niece was
like
getting or something
>> time. Maybe it might be another protester, but they'll
die.
>> Pause at 27 seconds in.
It's not really a whole lot there. I mean, it's just [snorts]
Yeah, it's just a guy, right? That's about it. And so, and uh
let him die. Sorry. I don't want to let these people die. I think
that's terrible. Like, I I think that if you have to somebody
in this situation, you have to do that, right? You do. You have
to do that. But the fact is that a lot of these people are victims
of propaganda. They're victims of propaganda the same way that,
you know, anybody else could be. You know, Iraq. >> Okay.
Look at the dinosaur.
>> Thank you. What?
>> I just want to see you react to the dinosaur, bro.
>> It's a chicken.
>> Groc, is this real? Yeah. It's like the first thing
I thought of is like, "Wait a minute. Are we watching an AI video?"
>> All right, bro. >> You want to come at us? You
want to come at us? >> All right, dog. >> You want
to come at us? I say >> absolutely
aggressive violent intent.
You have somebody want to come out
>> really drive. It's just it's insane what's going on
here.
>> Not even remotely the point. But why is there a Tyrannosaurus
in the driveway? Yeah, dude. When I saw that, I was like, "Wait
a minute." The first thing I thought of is did somebody AI this
whole video and then they put the Tyrannosaurus in there in order
to prove that it was AI that nobody would notice. And I was like
oh my god did the entire internet including vice president just
>> there's another little baby dinosaur over here. I didn't
see that at first. Wow. Just get tricked. But because that would
be clever, right? It would be clever. And so that's why I was
just pausing there for a second. I was like kind of like doing
mental calculations there. I was like, "Wait a minute. Wait.
want to sh somebody. They don't want to tase somebody. They don't
want to detain somebody. They don't want to arrest somebody.
Do you do you want to know how I know that? It's because it takes
>> for anything else here. I don't know if we're looking
for anything else here on on this immediate stuff.
>> Creators who lied to you, who tried to misrepresent
things to you, who gave you advice that put your life in danger,
and then people like nine days into the year, I guess. So, this
is going to make the left look more weak and pathetic. That's
hard to do, but somehow I think it'll be able to do that. You're
right. Yeah. And she's a victim of escalating tension. She is.
She's a victim of escalating tension. And I feel like this is
so sad. And I really hope that Reddit and I hope that all these
other social media websites Oh, we might have to go through this
a little bit as well. Okay.
Uh I saw a video of some city in northern Iran burning. Now,
I do wonder if we're going to get the the whole map or whatever
of
Dude, if if there's an Iranian
dude, you're going to see Fentes go the
I You are
cuz again, the whole clean break memo that he narrative that
he does, that whole narrative gets reinforced more and more every
time one of these like these um Arab majority nations falls apart.
Yeah, it it does. And and Fenta is going to sell that to people
and they're going to believe it and that's a little
>> Little spooky to me.
Maybe the worst commentator in the scene. Well, the unfortunate
thing full of hell is that he's not the worst commentator. He's
actually quite funny to listen to. He's actually quite like adept
at speaking through stuff. I just think he's incredibly ideologically
captured. So,
harmful. Yeah, it's um you say he's the worst commentator. It's
like depends on what you mean by good, I guess. Here, let's see
if we can pull up some of the stuff from Iran real quick in the
middle of this.
>> Dude, what in the is going on with my music? Where did
I end up on my music page? What the hell?
>> [__] weird.
I don't even know what this music is. This is weird in the background.
Damn.
Okay, what am I doing? I was going to go to scent defender. Yeah,
let's see. How far back do I have to go incentive vendor to see
a little bit
there? Go back to here.
US Secretary of State Marco Rubio spoke to with NATO Secretary
General Mark Rutz to discuss ongoing efforts to end the Russian
invasion of Ukraine as well as Okay, Arctic security stuff, not
that. Um, earlier this week or early this week, US intelligence
assessed that the ongoing anti-government protest in Iran lacks
suff lacks sufficient energy to challenge the stability of the
regime officials told Axios. But that view is reportedly being
reassessed in light of recent events. The protests are serious
and we will continue to monitor them. A senior a senior US official
said
this is Trump stuff.
Oh, this dude, there's no way. Over three minutes of footage
published by Secretary of Homeland State Secretary of Homeland
Security Christy Gnome from this morning boarding and seizure
of a stateless sanctioned oil tanker. Okay, I'm looking for
footage appeared uh published by Iran International which appears
to show multiple bodies laying on the ground outside Algadir
Hospital in eastern Tran following massive anti-government protests
in the capital overnight on Thursday. Let me see if I can look
at this on stream. I kind of doubt it. Sorry, there are videos
of Iran burning. I just want to see a couple of the things from
before.
Oh, this is on the floor in the hospital. I see. It's not really
outside or if it's outside, it's like in some corridor some Well,
no, there's a vehicle. It's like right It's like at some loading
bay or something.
So, massive crowds of anti-government protesters tonight in northeastern
Iranian city of Mashad. Likely tens of thousands from a city
with a population of roughly 34 million. Sorry, 3.4 million.
3.4 million.
likely tens of I mean this video is not of tens of thousands.
Maybe maybe tens of thousands overall. Even even that view
I can't tell. Yeah. See this is more sparse back here than it
appears. When when I thought this was all protesters it's like
oh maybe but this is like totally sparse back here. This is like
a thousand people tops in this area.
CIA is on a generational run apparently recently. Yeah, seems
that way
Venezuelan. This was the one I was looking at. Dude, the entire
local government municipality building in northern Iranian city
of Kurage is currently engulfed in flames as anti-government
protests appear to be on the verge of overflowing in Iran. Dude,
this was nuts.
But you never know how much of this is propaganda to be honest
with you that they're like trying to create the appearance of
like there's a popular uprising to get more people. You think
there's like some on the ground support. So you you kind of feain
you kind of massage this to look more like a popular uprising,
right?
And try to get more people who are who are sitting in their homes
to come out and participate.
Oh, what was this from? >> Nobody thought were Iran's in
big trouble. It looks to me that the people are taking over certain
cities that nobody thought were really
>> Dude, this was this was a little crazy. Okay, did you
guys see this? Have you seen this whole thing? Didn't Iran take
down the internet? I have no idea. Didn't you Did you guys see
this though where Trump was like he basically said if Iranian
if the Iranian government starts shooting peaceful protesters,
we'll go in. We'll put boots on the ground in Iran.
Dude, that's that's crazy to me, right? He says that and then
Oh, they did take down their internet. Okay, Elon sending Starlink.
He said that and then his government shoots somebody in the face
and he totally lies about it. No. Thank god this guy's alive.
He's recovering a hospital now. >> Hospital just a few
weeks ago. Uh we're watching the situation very carefully. I've
made the statement very strongly that if they start killing people
like they have in the past, we will get involved. We'll be hitting
them very hard where it hurts.
>> Have you seen the clip of Rubio Rubio sliding in the
note? Nope. >> And that doesn't mean boots on the ground,
but it means hitting him very
hurts. So, uh, we don't want that to happen. There have been
cases like this where President Obama totally backed
>> But this is something uh pretty incredible that's happening
in Iran. It's an amazing thing to watch.
>> Well, you can't really put you can't put boots on the
ground in Iran.
Um, boots on the ground in Iran is how you get a ton of people
killed, like a ton of your own people in a way that you But there
there's no air defense in Iran. Iran's air defense is entirely
gone. There's nothing that prevents Israel or the United States
from just like destroying that country, like leveling that country,
spending billions of dollars to do it. But like, you can't Yeah.
Putting boots on the ground in in Iran, it is literally like
a valley surrounded by mountains.
Getting boots on the ground there is crazy. You can air strike
it, but actually doing things there is pretty >> They've
done a bad job. They've treated their people very badly, and
now they're being paid back. So, let's see what happens. We're
watching it. We're watching it very closely. Iran's in big trouble.
It looks to me that the
>> What is this? What is this?
>> All right. Thank you, Mary. You You'll make it back
one way or the other. You're all going to do very well. I think
really very well. Marco,
dude, that's Marco Rubio's fault. Okay, this is the streamer
equivalent. Streamers will totally support Trump in this. If
you DM me something while I'm on stream, I'm going to assume
it's public. Okay,
you can't DM me something while I'm live and then go, "OH MY
GOD, YOU'RE NOT supposed to read that on
Well, you can especially lots of people will say don't read this
on stream but and it's like I won't read that and I'll go oh
this is what's happening in my DM. Okay. So it's difficult. It's
difficult. >> All right. Thank you. You you'll make it
back this slides it over. >> Well, I think really very
well. Marco just gave me a note. Go back to Chevron.
They want to discuss something. Go ahead. I'm going back to Chevron
Mark. Thank you, Marco.
Dude, these guys are so clearly run by oil exacts. It's actually
very funny. Go back. Go back to Chevron. Did I not see also Tucker
Carlson meeting with some oil exacts earlier today? Did I put
this tweet somewhere? I didn't. I know I didn't. Dude, I'm so
bad about this. Tucker Carlson oil. I think Tucker Carlson was
here and he was like in the room with the oil exacts and
Why is Tucker Carlson here? [__] is he doing here?
Why? Why
you supposed to you you expect me to believe this is the leader
of like your populist movement? Your populist uprising against
the like global homo elite that want to rule over you?
Yeah, for sure. Absolutely. For sure,
dude. Crazy. >> Is there was there a question, Mr. >> Yes.
Go ahead, Marco. What was it? What are you saying here? >> Mark,
if if you can update us on operations in the ground and with
the appropriate approvals, what you might be able to achieve
in the next 12 to 18 months. G give us a little view from the
>> You bet. You bet. So, today Chevron has 3,000 employees
in four different joint ventures in Venezuela today and over
>> Oh, not Uncle Pep Pepe Looney. Okay,
What is this?
We're just clicking
>> Hi, I'm Renee.
>> Okay. What is this?
3,000 views. Is this your own tweet? I just have to make sure.
Clearly AI. Bad AI.
Okay. Please don't have like slurs in here or something, okay?
For the love of God. >> Hi, I'm Renee and this is Jackass.
Okay, dude. Okay, dude.
Whatever. Not even not even that good. Although, damn. Uncanny
crazy. Okay.
All right. We're done with the Trump stuff. I'm back to scent
defender. We're going to keep taking a look at some of this.
Fires burn inside the bank Kesharzi Bank of Agriculture in the
city of Shiraz in southern Iran.
not about Iran, about Honduras.
Fires burned and crowds of anti-government protesters estimated
to be well over 100,000 were seen occupying the highway and other
major roads earlier tonight in Mashad, northeastern Iran. Mashad
seems to be the place where things popping off. Okay,
hold on. Let me go.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
O, saw my bookmarks there for a second. What is wrong with Twitter?
Why won't Twitter videos load?
Hello, Twitter. Hello.
This video won't load for me.
Dude, what is going on, man? Absolutely.
>> Damn. Anybody speak Arabic?
That does look like a lot of like more people, but again, I can't
tell. The numbers are I don't know about the numbers they're
estimating here. Also, are these guys setting a forest fire on
a like highway that they're all out on?
Do we think that's wise?
They don't speak Arabic. Wait. Oh, sure. Um, it's not Persian
literally, is it?
They're saying America, America, come save us. No, they're not.
Farsy. Farsy. Okay. Sorry, I didn't know the language. I realized
I said Arabic.
Yeah, I I said Arabic and I didn't even think about the ethnicity
of these people.
Tucker Carlson would chastise me if I was arguing for them to
be invaded. Okay. Just like Ted Cruz.
Same [__] It's not the same [__] It's
different. It's different.
Okay. All right,
dude. I guess we're back to some of this Minnesota stuff. I'm
looking around for like more tweets on this. I was just going
to watch some Asthma Gold reactions to this because I figured
he was going to be going off on it all day. But we might go to
maybe this oil press conference and then we'll see from
Oh, dude. This is actually
This would be truly
this could be an incredible day
for like Tik Tok memes if we could get like Tik Tok soy videos.
There's got to be somebody tracking like soy post soy post from
Tik Tok, right? immigration >> went from defending Somalian
scammers, Tesla bombings, drug boats, Maduro, Hamas, Charlie
Kirk, attempted Trump assassination, Iran, Luigi, MS-13, trans
kids, running over ice, illegal. >> That's true. >> He's
just going to
mean this is all this is all in one
>> Really think about how like really look at all of this.
This is insane.
They This is the party of mental Oh, speaking of mental illness,
I forgot about this one.
Almost. She was trying to run him over. It's self-defense. I
wish she was. Almost. She was trying to run him over. It's self-defense.
I wish she was. And I wish she did. And guess what? If she did
and he died, I would have celebrated because ice aren't people.
their demons in human form.
If she did and he died, I would have celebrated because ice people.
They're demons in human form.
Do you know how I got these scars?
I went to art school.
Oh, maybe we have to check up this whole Trump meeting with the
oil people. Okay. Not just the memes.
Oh, what am I getting linked?
somebody somebody ping me.
Uh, this guy has to be timed out now for like an hour. Sorry.
Don't ping me while I'm streaming with nonsense. Don't do that.
Thank you. Thank you.
Back to the stream. >> $60,000 of student debt.
>> It's the SSRI Joker.
Oh god,
this crazy needs to be locked
Oh man, [snorts] this is just insane, isn't it? Yeah, she got
Bro, she's she she's she's doubled up. She got two rings on her
nose. Yeah, it's just so crazy, isn't it? Oh my god. So, watch
this.
This is insane.
One more.
Looks pretty crazy.
That's more looking like thousands and thousands of people. Now,
when you have like the long parade of people,
you're looking at like both sides of this and it's just like
going
off into the distance in both directions. That's pretty concerning.
I do think it's really stupid to have this many people on like
a highway like this and then you set fires on one of the sides.
So, like the trees on one of the sides, that seems pretty crazy
as well in the middle of the desert. But just me personally wouldn't
do that. They're all Msade. Well, I don't think it's all MSAD.
I'm just saying that this is this regime has been destabilized
pretty significantly at this point.
What is that? This is in Iran. This is in Thrron. It it says
the fall of Thyron. Actually, I don't think this is in Thrron.
It looks to be the same place judging by the the trees here.
I do believe this is in that northern city.
is that the one we were looking at earlier from the scent vendor
tweets? I think so.
I should go. Do we have um
would anybody be tracking this with an OSN map already? I'm sure
somebody would be it was this city. Uh Mashad. Yeah, Mashad in
northeastern Iran. This looks to be the same place right between
these two.
I would say that's the same place. You're on a highway. You got
like these uh whatever these I don't know leafless trees are
out here.
Live UA map. Yeah, that's what I'm looking for. >> I wonder
if there would be one for Iran right now. Like tracking
tracking protests.
Let's see.
>> Trying to click into it right now.
>> State media published footage they claim showed protesters
firing at security guards in Kerman.
or are you just not going to work? Are you a Twitter video just
not going to work at all?
Okay. Well, that's what's happening with Twitter video right
now. It seems like
nope. Got nothing.
I don't know. Anyway, this is uh showing
I dude is is my internet what is going on? Why is everything
right now? Oh,
I see.
Back over. There we go. Now we're good. Now we're good. This
is Tran. Okay, so there are protests out in Tran. Crowds of protesters
poured the streets. Protesters. Protesters.
None of these videos are going to work. Okay. Uh we're probably
not going to use this site again.
Anyway, um this sort of gives you an idea. I guess there is a
lot of stuff in Tron. Here's Mashad over here. They got like
the fires and [__] happening
now. I thought this out here
is this where they wrote like they basically took over the government
in one of these cities there. There's like a governor who declared
like independence I believe
if that would be here.
Protesters. Protesters.
Yeah, I need to spend some time looking further into this. Okay,
fly to Iran. Give us some underground reporting. I will not I
have to look I have to look further into the Iran stuff to really
cover it. Well, which sucks. >> Back up. >> I'm I'm
far enough away. I'm not.
>> Here we go.
>> I'm going to ask you guys directly. Can I get some Can
anybody help me out? Grab me a time stamp for Hassan when he
gets to the botting stuff.
If somebody's got a moment to do that, just say so in chat. I'm
looking for the time stamp for when Hassan gets to the botting
stuff with anything. live on the street. I'm going to start fighting
over that. We'll cover some drama. >> No, I won't. >> Maybe
skip over the stuff and come back
one of our cars as well. You were too close right now. You were
interfering right here in my face. I'm a public. No, I won't.
Tell me why I'm far enough away from your investigation. Step
[snorts] beyond our car. >> Don't touch me. Please go.
Where's your >> Right here. Where's your car? Oh, that's
>> Get out of here, Karen.
>> Was it today? Yeah, it was today.
This is like the This is the nose ring for the ears.
You see a woman with these hoop earrings.
This is a nose ring for the ears.
Like an earring. Like a Wow, he's discovered earrings now. That's
a
dude. Hoop earrings are a That's a big one. Christian also have
those. Yeah. Didn't she dog or something?
It's kind of crazy. Who does that?
>> Sure. I'll be on your car. 20 ft. Right. Do that white
car. I have a six-year-old right here. I have a six-year-old
right here in my car. >> Massive mistake. This should >> insane.
I'm sorry. I can't do I can't do just like unrestricted asthma
gold right now. I >> I thought I could do it for a little
bit. I can't. I can't actually do it.
>> That'll teach me to just show up to stream without anything.
I've got like other videos that are longer, but honestly, I was
kind of enjoying this for a little bit.
>> I'm gonna go listen.
>> Let's do this real quick.
>> Something else a little different. Little different
flavor here.
Wait, I need to go to settings.
Where's the old Reddit thing?
I I'm going to check this out for a quick second. Okay, >> I'm
sorry.
>> I don't have I have no idea how my music got to this.
This is [__] crazy. >> SHAME. SHAME. >> Do
you have >> paid protesters says the quiet part?
>> Do you have a job? >> Shame. Shame. I'M GETTING
PAID RIGHT
WHY DOES she look so happy?
>> Oh, I'm on some I'm on some old Whoops.
You go what? Hot. I think you by hot.
>> There we go.
Oh, look at him. Someone get that [__] on record.
>> Let's search the sky.
>> Wow. Wow. >> Now somebody is dead.
Everybody who advocated
drive away. Everybody who said ICE our secret police don't listen
are as Mongolians really sing. I prefer as Mongaloids but really
sing for ICE agents right now.
I just figured I'd check out the subreddit because this is this
gets all
everybody who said that uh you know oh you know like make sure
to fight back against ICE put your body on the line they are
the ones that are responsible for this We